les familles à propos de la loyauté
quand vous nous acceptez immédiatement vous
vivrez Je fais face aux conséquences que vous avez trouvées en
contractant ne signifie pas seulement une
livraison
oh mon dieu qu'est-ce que tu fais Dave Sharpe
quoi de neuf alors ouais voici le paquet
Edna Montoya ceci  est un [ __ ] de
bar délicieux et [ __ ] de saké pourrait prendre un
autre travail ici avec le contrôle du nom
ouais pour un mineur je suis Stella
nous avons beaucoup de frères qui l'ont traversé
vous semblez fatigué c'est ce qui se passe quand
vous apportez des événements quelqu'un est pris
derrière
l'avertissement c'est ça
[Musique]
car tu pourrais t'en tirer avec un professeur
cette vie tu n'es pas toujours bonne pour nous
nous avons besoin de seins Le Coran nous donne ces règles
il n'y a pas de diable
[Musique]